Aurel que pensez-vous l'écriture
inclusive que ferez-vous pour défendre
protégées promouvoir la langue française
alors ça c'est un de mes combats figur
ez-vous au réel parce que j'avais
questionné Edouard Philippe en son temps
après que
des articles soient sortis sur
l'écriture inclusive je pense que c'est
une véritable catastrophe cette écriture
inclusive c'est née de l'Observatoire de
la parité fallait donner plus de
visibilité au féminin dans la langue
mais vous savez
la langue évolue elle est vivante il
s'agit pas de figer la langue dans
l'état ancien qu'elle a connu parce que
sinon on exigerait de parler en anciens
français ça n'a pas de sens donc la
langue elle évolue le vocabulaire évolue
et même l'orthographe de certains mots à
évolué et c'est normal mais c'est
l'usage qui fait évoluer la langue
c'est pas l'idéologie qui fait
et quand je vois les désordres auxquels
aujourd'hui on est confronté chacun fait
sa petite sauce dans son coin et décrète
des règles qui lui semblent bonnes en la
matière et donc on va écrire chef au
féminin avec un S avec deux F voilà en
fonction de son humeur de ce qui nous
semble bien ça n'est pas possible
d'abord faut penser aux enfants qui
apprennent l'orthographe même si
c'est un enseignement qui a beaucoup
décliné mais je crois que l'orthographe
le code qui régit le fonctionnement de
la langue ça permet tout simplement de
parler la même langue et d'écrire la
même langue
et on arrive à des aberrations comme le
pronom Yale qui n'a aucun sens donc
il y a deux ans j'ai réuni à l'Assemblée
nationale un groupe de travail avec des
philosophes des sociologues des
grammairiens
pour réfléchir à cette question comment
on protège la langue comment
protège-t-on la langue parce que
l'Académie française n'a qu'un rôle
limité en la matière et cela va donner
lieu à l'édition d'un livre qui va être
publié à l'automne dont j'ai écrit la
préface et qui fait intervenir à un
certain nombre de spécialistes de cette
question et qui vont écrire sur
l'écriture
inclusive qui ne se limite pas au point
médian ni à la féminisation des titres
moi on m'appelle madame la députée ça ne
me pose aucun problème il y a des usages
qui ne posent aucun problème il y a des
usages qui sont véritablement
problématiques et il faut il faut y
mettre bon ordre je crois